CHET HAASE: Hi.
I'm Chet Haase, an engineer on
the android team at Google.
I gave a talk with Romain Guy
at Google IO recently called
"A Moving Experience," in which
we talked about various
cartoon animation techniques
that you could apply to user
interfaces.
One of those techniques is
called squash and stretch.
And we're going to show a demo
today that shows some of that,
as well as another technique
that kicks in called
exaggeration.
So the idea with squash and
stretch is that objects in the
real world deform to some
extent, especially when they
hit say, a wall.
If a body hits a wall or hits
the ground going very fast,
it's not going to stay in
exactly the same shape that it
was before it hit that
unmoving object.
So maybe it's good if you want
your objects to have more of a
real-world feel, or more organic
and natural feel, to
actually give them some
elements of this
stretchability as well.
And the other element is
exaggeration, which is the
idea from cartoons is you want
to make it very obvious what's
going on and also add
a playful aspect.
So not only would things deform
slightly, but maybe
they would deform much more than
that, just to exaggerate
and enhance the effect and
really let the user know
exactly what's going on.
So let's see how this
works in a demo.
We have a very simple demo
where when I click on the
button, the button is going to
fall down to the bottom of the
screen with gravity.
But before it bounces back up,
we've got this feeling that
the button is this more elastic
and rubbery material.
And so when it hits the ground,
it's actually going to
adhere a little bit, and squash
and stretch out before
finally snapping back and then
bouncing back up to its
starting position.
I've enabled a menu item so we
can slow this thing down, so
we can see it in a little bit
more glorious detail.
And you'll notice that we're
actually deforming the button
as it falls as well.
So it's not just when it
hits the floor at the
bottom of the screen.
But also as it's falling, the
object is actually stretching
out according to gravity
a little bit.
It's very subtle.
It's hard to catch when it's
running at full speed, but it
also indicates to the user the
subtle aspect of this button
is interacting physically more
with its environment than
buttons typically do.
So let's take a look
at the code.
It's actually fairly
straightforward animation code
using object animators and
Property Values Holders to
animate these things
in sequence.
First of all, we calculate the
animation duration based on
whether we've enabled the
Scaling option there so that
we can see the animation
run really slowly.
We set the Pivot Point.
This is not necessary, but it
made some of the code a little
bit simpler so that we didn't
have to sort of change the
translation and scale around
a particular point.
So we set the Pivot Point that
all the scales will happen
around to the bottom
of the object.
And then we use Property Values
Holder to animate
several properties on the same
target object in parallel.
We're going to animate the
translation y as well as the
scale x and scale y properties
on the way down.
So we're going to move the
object down, and as we move
it, we're going to stretch it
out in y and we're going to
squish it in in x as it goes.
We're going to create the down
animation with a single object
animator using these
three Property
Values Holder objects.
We're going to set an
interpolator to an Accelerate
Interpolator because we want it
to look like it's reacting
to gravity and actually
going faster the
further down it falls.
And then we're going to set the
Duration according to the
duration we calculated before.
Once we hit the bottom, then
we're going to stretch out in
x and squash down in y like a
rubbery object might if it hit
such a hard thing as a floor.
So we're going to use again
Property Values Holders to
animate scale x and scale
y in parallel.
The Stretch animation is going
to use those Property Values
Holders directly.
We're going to set a Repeat
Counter repeat mode.
So we want it to squash and
stretch out, and then we want
it to snap back to
where it was.
So it's the same animation
running in reverse according
to the Repeat Count and
repeat mode here.
We're going to set an
Interpolator Decelerator here
so as it stretches out, I wanted
this feeling of the
rubbery material having
this tension.
The further out it goes, the
slower it's going to go until
it finally reaches the end
and then snaps back.
And as it snaps back, it's going
to use the reverse of
deceleration.
So it's going to accelerate,
which is what again this
elastic or rubbery
object would do.
And then we're going to animate
back to the top.
So again, we're just animating
translation y and scale x and
scale y-- basically the reverse
of what we did before,
including using a decelerator to
give the effect of pulling
up against gravity and then
slowing as it reaches the top
of the curve, ready
to go again.
We're going to use an
Animator Set to put
these things together.
We're going to play
them in sequence.
So first we animate down.
Then we stretch and squash
out, repeat that
back to where it was.
And then we run the
up animation.
And that's it.
Thanks.